[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá a todos
eu fazia minha apresentação velho ditado
português
água mole em pedra dura tanto bate até
que fura
porque não quis fazer um processo de
produção do grafeno e é um pouco também
aqui o que eu sinto na minha vida e
neste projecto em que estou envolvido
o que então o grafeno é o o o grafeno é
é uma única única camada de átomos de
carbono com um arranjo hexagonal
estupros físicos mais mais turistas
no caso da indústria que menos
conservadora considera que o grafeno
pode ter entre 13 a 15 camadas a e por
isso a atribuição dos nomes de grafeno
de poucas camadas d e multicamadas as
metas de produção estão divididos em
duas abordagens a abordagem top-down
links para uma fotografia como minério
matéria prima e isso vai diminuindo o
número de chamadas até chegar a um
número mínimo e abordagem à porta mas
como é o caso da oposição que emitem
fazê lo porém que se constrói camada a
camada controladamente obviamente que
cada uma delas tem prós e contras em
termos de preço e qualidade e quantidade
também
este material ficou conhecida em 2004
quando os investigadores usaram um
método muito rudimentar pela atenção eu
simplesmente colaram fita cola sobre um
pedaço de grafite e arrancar o grupo
também estava pronto material com apenas
duas dimensões
esta descoberta é foi tão racional que
em 2010 estes dois investigadores foram
laureados com o prémio nobel da física
chamei mais desculpa
não interessa é ok
ultimamente o mercado deste deste
material
esse ponto é alta em três mercados
atingir os compósitos avançados
eletrônica ea energia a um mercado que
nós achamos que o grafeno pode
desempenhar um papel mais importante e
mais rápido nos compra no mercado
compósitos avançados até porque o time
tomar que a crise é necessário neste
produto é bastante mais discutido com os
outros nos outros dois
neste nicho influências tintas
condutoras ou usar o grafeno como
aditivo para reforço à força um mecânico
quanto ao mercado da eletrônica que pode
também fazer uso das tintas com todas
o grafeno pode permitir desenvolver da
eletrônica flexível eletrônica e
impressa e até mesmo os filmes com torço
pra quem não sabe essa indústria está
pronto um problema sério porque um dos
materiais mais usados para fazer tantos
crimes de touchscreen dispositivos é o
oxi vídeo do padre constantino e este
tal este material tem tem tem ficado a
escassos mundialmente e os seus preços
têm vindo feita escalar o movimento no
mercado no dia o grafeno pode ser o
utilizado na nba triagem super
condensadores que têm propriedades muito
positivas como áreas sociais grande e
ativa elétrica bom água mole em pedra
dura tanto bate até que fura
foi exatamente com este provérbio que eu
comecei a minha apresentação
esta é a nossa tecnologia onde a empresa
diz o diretor científico do desenvolveu
e está dividido em três partes o parto
nós fazemos captação ultrassônica forças
de corte e e em conta sua condição
térmica é um processo tem vantagens
movimentar as outras atuais são elas
churrascos tu o fax e escalável e e será
com eficiente porque não usa químicos é
possível e nós manipulamos estas cinco
variável ea temperatura cai da bolha da
competição vencida potência de
acreditação
a concentração da matéria prima e o tipo
de dispersante
o que isto não é este de acreditação
ultra sônico que que é tão usada em
aplicações metade como na na na
monitorização dos submarinos ou em
joalheria né eletrônica e limpeza de
superfícies adaptação das puro
propagação de ondas numa equipe como
essa quando as ondas passam por ciclos a
opção e baixa opção em baixa a opção
criam sovacos voith quando regressam
assim como a opção envolvem isso e batem
isso na superfície numa superfície ao
bater em uma superfície cria uma
instituição
essa exposição não é totalmente
controlada e é por isso que surgem duas
posições uma exatamente a exposição ea
outra a fragmentação de partículas que
já foram
foi aliás é uma fotografia do nosso
sistema desculpa não podemos mostrar
tudo isto está sobre segredo
o material ainda não têm um padrão lutas
ainda científica e politicamente para
determinar o que exatamente o grafeno
nós avaliamos características que este
material tem som ela já o tamanho
natural da partícula o número de camadas
o número do fat e nível de contaminação
para isso usamos surto estas duas
técnicas chuva vocês podem ver nestas
imagens e espectroscopia raman faz uso
da interação da luz com a matéria e que
consegue pela assinatura do que é
material por ser neste caso o número de
camadas de nível frente e no caso da
microscopia neste neste caso também da
microscopia eletrônica de transmissão é
possível terminar é igualmente número de
camadas e o comprimento total ficando
cada uma destas destas partículas
assim é possível saber onde estamos
perante um grande ano poucas camada
sombras e multicamadas atualmente
desenvolve várias ações que já
apresentou as contas pra eletrônica
impressa
estamos também fazer investimentos
diretos para aplicação de tratamento da
água onde a ação
é tem que aguentar uma vez estava
correndo muito valor à volta de cinco
mil ampéres por metro quadrado ram e era
preciso proteger estes elétrons dessas
condições
estamos também agora com 19 pontos
conseguiu eletromagnético podem
desempenhar um papel muito importante no
futuro sobretudo nos carros elétricos
estão cheios eletrônica no seu interior
é possível e é preciso proteger toda
essa eletrônica possíveis bilheterias e
também penso que no futuro vai ser muito
importante os filmes por médicos
cooperados gerando inclusive fosse vagas
e aqui o prefeito pode desempenhar um
papel muito grande vamos investir em
superfícies poliméricas que está em
perfeito vai poder aparecer suspeitos de
sempre ativa olho nu e substituir por
exemplo meninas porque as embalagens do
do alimento como o tcm quanto ao futuro
seria muito bom ser possível utilizar a
nossa a nossa a nossa condição médica
constantemente ao perceberem porque
etapa já com um determinado alimento há
pessoas na sua profissão ou saber que
condições em que condição está um vinho
estavam para ser consumido antes de
antes de abrir a própria garrafa
isto vai ser possível e e primeiro é
preciso fazer um caminho até chegarmos
lá e tem neste caso do programa tem que
seduzir os seus custos de produção e
aumentar muito a sua escala e é
exatamente isso que nós estamos a tentar
fazer
eu falei já pouco da habitação e da água
mole em pedra dura tanto bate até que
fura e eu gostaria de acabar com uma
frase motivadora captação e pendentes
duas variáveis a freqüência ea potência
se você encontrar a voz em terceiro
lugar certo que esta tenha sido a nossa
freqüência não há nenhuma pedra seja tão
dura quanto vocês não consigam partir
[Aplausos]
[Música]